well ingrid newkirk actually sorry to
keep going back to peta i'm completely
obsessed with taking them down uh ingrid
newkirk the president of peta she they
brag all the time oh she only takes a 30
000 a year salary she look at this great
human she really cares about animals
even though she's completely lobbying
for all pit bulls to be eradicated there
to be no pets in human homes including
cats and dogs and that she has
personally killed thousands of dogs with
her own hands
but she is worth millions of dollars
despite taking only this 30 000 a year
salary i can explain how this works um i
can't speak for peta specifically i can
speak for other organizations and i can
explain to you
501c3 you guys want a 501c3 nonprofit
organization it's uh tax deductible
non-political and these are the
organizations you have to often hear
about where they say you know your
donation to us is tax deductible in
certain circumstances they will and then
they'll say our executive director only
takes forty thousand dollars a year
because they are good and noble mm-hmm
what they don't tell you is that they
operate a 501c4
another kind of non-profit uh 51c4 is
also uh i believe they they it's the
designation for super pacs as well they
don't need to disclose their donations
it's not tax deductible and that's where
they pay the big bucks so what will
happen is you'll have two non-profits a
501c3 and a 501c4 the 501c3 does all the
press and announces our executive
director gets paid nothing and what they
don't tell you because they don't have
to is that the director also gets paid
another couple hundred thousand dollars
out of the pocket of the 501c4 and when
you make a donation often you don't read
the fine print and you don't realize
you're actually donating to the 501c4
and then that what happens is some of
these organizations will take all the
money in the 501c4 and they'll tell you
like oh you know what because we do
political work we're not tax deductible
and then what happens is when they make
100 million dollars into their 501c4
they give only but 5 million to the
501c3 then they come back to you and say
last year we only brought in five
million dollars
and our executive director only makes
thirty thousand years
i did not know that that's incredible
it's money laundering
it's legal it's legal there there are
non-profits they're brilliant what they
do they'll organize like 10 different
non-profits and there'll be like nine
people and they'll rotate the board of
directors of each non-profit and they
all
circulate funding it's amazing this
industry what they're doing is pretty
impressive too they're they're going
around right now and they're just trying
to set precedence for future cases so
they're going to roadside zoos they're
going to small farms they're going to
all these different places where people
have exotic animals and whether they're
cared for well or not
they're going in there they're
suing them they're filing esa
lawsuits against them claiming that they
have standing to seize these animals the
judges are siding with them but they're
doing it to people who don't have the
money to fight back because these
organizations are huge and they're
spending millions of dollars and so
they're setting all these precedents now
so they can go after the bigger people
later um actually
john pierce you guys have had on from
the nclu has a whole bunch of client he
took on my friend tanya who had her
chimps taken from her by peta last month
and now all these people who have been
victims of peter are coming out of the
woodwork and he's investigating their
cases
and it looks like people are going to
start fighting back finally because
they're teaming up together
and i'm very excited for it because i am
like furious about them i want to i want
to ask you guys a question but first i
i'll tell you a little story i was
reading this in like i can't remember
what it was it was an old timey like law
precedence book was probably like one of
those magazines you read in the bathroom
or something and it said that there was
an old case where like two farmers had
land that butted up against each other
and uh one one you know farmer a his dog
kept going on to the farmer bee's land
and farmer b kept getting mad saying get
your dog off my property and the guy was
like i'm sorry you know get over here
you know fido and then one day farmer b
took out his gun and shot the dog and
killed it
and then farmer a was like you killed my
dog how dare you and the court said
you know property loss your dog
shouldn't have gone on to his property
so he owes you the damages for the lost
property and i remember reading that
being like my dog is not property
my dog is a friend
and if you do anything to my friends
john which brings me to the question
if someone came to your home
and took your dog
and then killed it for no reason what
would you do
i can't see what i would do or the feds
will knock on my door hold on are you is
this are we talking about john wick here
yeah is that well let's just say they
made a movie about it which ended up
becoming what are they on they're going
on movie four now yeah because the dude
wanted to be left alone and some dudes
killed his dog and john wick what an
awesome oh i got a story here it's from
a few years ago from the guardian peta
says sorry for taking girls pet
chihuahua and putting it down
animal rights group pays family 49 000
to set a lawsuit after it seized a dog
named maya which belonged to a
nine-year-old they say wilbur zarate
from virginia had sued the group for
taking his daughter's chihuahua from a
mobile home park on the state's eastern
shore and euthanizing it before the end
of the required five-day grace period
zarate alleged pita operate under a
broad policy of euthanizing animals
including healthy ones because it
considers pet ownership to be a form of
involuntary bondage that's right so you
just kill the the animal that makes
sense wow peter denied the allegation
and maintained the incident was a
terrible mistake i'm sorry i've seen a
ton of videos on reddit there was one
surveillance footage where you see
someone actually run under the porch and
grab an animal have you seen that one
yeah that's crazy have you seen the foot
the photos of peta like they're they
used to dump the carcasses of dogs into
walmart dumpsters and stuff huffington
post actually did an incredible expose i
hate praising the huffington post but it
was incredible
um
because they were just killing all these
dogs and they had nowhere to put them so
they were throwing them in dumpsters and
the
state inspector for virginia actually
did a report being like how are you
taking in this many dogs when you don't
have any place to put them how is this a
shelter and they wanted to shut it down
but peter used their big lobbying money
to to keep running
and they killed more dogs last year than
they did the year before that how many
uh uh you probably know the answer but
ian sheamus feel free to chime in and
for those listening at home feel free to
throw in your super chats with your
guesses in today's trivia question how
many dogs does peta kill every year
twenty thousand
you know what's funny i have no idea
what it is but i was also going to guess
twenty thousand well that is a full uh
that is that is ten times too many it's
two thousand dogs in catch well they
don't
actually is only the numbers for their
virginia shelter where they kill animals
they used a whole bunch of their
donations instead of throwing adoption
events they used them to buy giant
freezers for carcasses hope you all peta
donors know that but um they actually
travel to mexico as well and they go
down there and euthanize all the street
dogs and those numbers are not counted
really they also take they seize animals
from all these little roadside zoos and
sanctuaries those numbers are not
counted there's currently a lion missing
they seized a lion from a
arrest there's a lion oh let me tell you
guys this story gosh
so there's a sanctuary rescue in
maryland the guy takes like exotic pets
that have been thrown away that people
can't care for cancer tiger king
uh no
way better
but he
um
actually the nclu is going to be
representing some people from tiger king
and that's a whole interesting other
story that i'll get into one day
but um there's this place and he takes
like exotic throwaway pets think people
you know people go get a tiger or a
monkey and then they can't care for it
this guy takes them
so he had two tigers and a lion
and
peta filed a lawsuit against them saying
he was violating the esa because the
lion liked him too much they said that
it was too bonded to the caretaker and
therefore it was unnatural and the court
sided with them sent the line and the
two tigers to a rest uh shelter i mean a
sanctuary in colorado and now he went to
go visit him in i believe february of
last year i could be wrong
and he said that they looked terrible
like they were in great shape when he
had him now they look terrible and now
nobody has seen him since and so i
actually called the sanctuary asking if
i could get proof of life
and because nobody has seen them and
this place is open to the public they
let people take public tours
which makes means it's basically the
same thing he was doing but um
they wouldn't they told me there's no
recent photos but that they're
supposedly alive
um and so now he's he's trying to get
proof of life and nobody will give it to
him
so
i mean peta
the things that i've learned in the last
couple weeks have been keeping me up at
night about what this organization oh
i'm sure yeah and i'm i'm definitely
here for the pita bashing but also at
the same time but also at the same time
i think when we're treating human beings
the way that we treat them i just don't
think there's any hope for animals
you have to be believing in nightmare
dystopias sheamus because you're living
in one it's true you better you better
believe in science fiction dystopia
stories
is it that peta is looking for animals
that they think are in like rough
situations and then they take them and
but then they can't support them so they
execute them well what they claim
so they don't believe that there should
be any animals in human care
there was a lawsuit that they they were
involved in where they said that no
elephants should be transported to this
zoo they said the elephants would be
better dead than in zoos and being fed
by humans that was where the whole
better dead than fed thing came from
but
they don't believe anybody should have
pets they don't believe you should have
a cat they don't even think you should
have a goldfish and so what they're
doing is they're going around trying to
shut down all these like smaller
sanctuaries who don't agree to play by
their rules don't agree to work with
them
and they're taking them and they're
sending them to these these other
sanctuaries through our courts it's
essentially civil asset forfeiture but
through a private organization and it's
a loophole in the esa which shouldn't
exist
the exotic
endangered species act
and
they're
they're sending them off to these places
but
they're not considering the welfare of
the animals for example
with tonya haddock's case they just went
and seized chimps from her in st louis
or near st louis
um these chimps were were bonded they
were a troop they were in a huge
enclosure that was bigger than my house
it was several stories tall it was
beautiful
but they claim that they know better and
so
last year they took three chimps from a
sanctuary put in a different sanctuary
called project chimps
and project chimps got them killed
because they put them in with random
chimps that they didn't know these
chimps were older they were retired from
research and from entertainment they
didn't have the alpha ability to defend
themselves
so they got killed and then 22
whistleblowers came out against project
chimp and alleged abuse
mistreatment filthy conditions all kinds
of stuff and peta didn't disavow them
the way that they do for all these
little sanctuaries that are operating
all over the country um instead they put
out a statement being like this is
terrible and continued working with them
so when they come in and they seize
these animals
they're putting them in great danger
and it's
yeah can i can i i want to highlight a
specific person though
her name is mary beth sweetland oh you
know who that is
she is uh apparently uh according to at
least one website called uh actually let
me just show it
this is humanewatch.org
mary beth sweetland is best known as the
peta executive who vigorously campaigned
against medical research with animals
even though she is a diabetic whose
health relies on injecting herself with
insulin that has been tested on animals
now over at peta they do she does say
that she's on what is this called uh
humulin a synthetically produced insulin
is much more appropriate for the human
body okay i can respect that that's from
2010 they say but i will also mention
that newsguard rates peta as caution the
website fails to adhere to several basic
journalistic standards i i know that
this is they call it fake news yeah they
are fake news today i was fighting with
the vp of peta on twitter because that
idiot made her way into my mentions
and
she put up to take a dig at me because
i've been defending tanya so hard she
put up a press release about what the
chimps in festus
and it was a photo of one of the cages
indoors that they use for like when they
need to tranquilize them or when they
need to go into clean cage it's like a
temporary enclosure and they didn't show
any of the rest of the property they
blamed her for things that happened 70
years ago when she's only been in charge
of the chimps since 2017.
they put up this like wild i mean
it was impressive how fake news it was i
was like holy crap like if i read this i
would be outraged i would be really
fascinated to know how these animal
rights activists who are against
experimenting on animals for the benefit
of humanity feel about the kind of
research we were discussing earlier with
unborn children oh you know peta
wouldn't care yeah i really doubt they'd
care at all no of course not they might
care about the rats oh my god you're so
so right yeah that is horrible you're so
right wow that's like the worst that's
horrible humans are animals i mean we're
ethical treatment of animals humans are
animals yes
so scientifically we're the smartest
animal but here's a question for
everyone here do you believe there's a
fundamental difference between humans
and animals yes no yeah humans are
absolutely i think absolutely you know
but i also deeply care about animals for
sure
you can still care about animals but
agree that like humans are superior i
once saw a very important uh film
i talked greatly about this it was
called all dogs go to heaven yes
good theologically inaccurate
no
no
great movie though they do go to heaven
i won't hear otherwise of course they do
what's the loophole do you know what
that loophole in the esa is that's
letting peta go in and um so they're
letting them claim standing because you
can't just go in and be like
i oppose war so i'm gonna oppose i'm
gonna sue lockheed martin and take all
the bombs and decide what to do with
them which was my fiancee's great
analogy here um but you can't that will
be based you can't
be extremely based but with the esa you
can because they the judges are claiming
the endangered species act so the judges
are claiming that because peta cares
about animals they have standing in
these cases what if we had like an
endangered humans act that could allow
you to uh sue people for mobbing people
in parts of the world where they're
killing civilians they're like bombing
civilians farms and fishing boats or
aiding governments that are bombing
farms is humans are far from endangered
that's all that's actually i did the
back yeah but
back humans are actually on a really
dangerous course yeah yeah so we may
have there may be lots of people but boy
i'll tell you this if we saw like a
bunch of chimps and one had an rpg we'd
be like they're in danger you know what
i mean we got nukes man
yeah yeah
yeah
they're peta is like taking people's
homes and stuff now though and it's
gotten to the point where it's insane um
there's this guy tim stark a lot of you
probably know him from tiger king
i was talking to him the other day
they're taking his home because they
they not only went and took all his
animals but then they sued for legal
fees which she has to recoup which came
i believe he was they were awarded 750
000
so not only are they getting these
animals they're getting almost a million
dollars and
um it's it's just crazy to me that like
this is even allowed but i was talking
to him and he made a great point that
under the endangered species act it
counts they count tigers because in the
wild they're endangered and so the
endangered species act is supposed to
apply to wild animals if you count all
the tigers that are in captivity in the
united states
because they're being the esa's being
applied to them they're not considered
endangered anymore because there's like
10 000 tigers in captivity or something
and so they're just using all these
weird bizarre loopholes to to create
precedent for future cases so they can
go after more people and bigger people
it's time for for people of good will to
uh stand up man
we need people to become more more
organized and more active
i guess the issue is that there's too
many
maybe maybe the fault lies with the
average working american who is i
wouldn't say comfortable in a sense i
mean you're always striving and
struggling in some respect but pulled
out of the fight in general i don't
think average americans need to be
involved in a battle against pete or
anything like that i just mean like all
of this well sure
i just i see all this bad stuff that's
happening whether it be the stuff we
normally rag about with you know uh with
with critical race applied principles
and now with you know what's going on
with these experiments and i'm like man
if people were just all
calm reasonable mature but active and
and voiced their opinions this stuff
would never happen
you can't voice your opinions half the
things that people want to say about
like
the way that you would want to respond
to people grafting dead baby parts onto
a rat would get you banned on any social
exact platform yes even discussing it
even talking about that happening not
only
it's not even just about social media
platforms if you bring that up in front
of people they're going to look at you
like you're crazy imagine if everyone
did yeah they should dude you know when
what's that not as an outrage the fact
that that happened and then also the
fact that the story broke a while ago
basically no one talked about at the
time and no one really knows about it
anymore now is insane didn't the u.s
order like photos to be taken as much as
possible after world war two so yeah yes
i remember that there you go yep and it
was a good thing
now people know exactly what was going
on and what we vowed and never let
happen again so
when when you see any of these stories
as horrible as they are how do we how do
we tolerate any of this it's it made me
think of north korea
young me park right or struggling so
like in north korea everyone's starving
so they don't have time to think about
anything other than where's my food i
need to get food and we need all they do
on purpose we're not starving and all we
think about is food and when we're gonna
get our next meal and how we can sit on
the couch and entertain ourselves in
front of the television or with our
smartphone i mean it's unbelievable
you know joseph stalin and mao zedong
and all these horrific dictators
historically did everything they could
to pull people away from god with
violence it turns out all you really
needed to do was develop your economy
enough for nice gadgets to be put in
everyone's hands and they would just
forget about him and then they would let
anyone treat anyone else any kind of way
and no one would stand up for the truth
because no one would have developed
enough virtue to do anything that was
even remotely difficult or compromised
their social standing remember uh
wall mounted phones
yes yeah i was watching a video on
reddit and it was like high def 1993 in
new york
and i was like oh you you poor fools you
have no no idea what lies ahead i think
the internet for all of its wonders
there's a lot of negatives to it because
for you know for every action is an
equal and opposite the internet's an
amazing stuff here we are you know
talking to you
but it's like you said jameis it's also
it's it's
man it's it's plugged people into this
machine where they've gone nuts
when here's what scares me
when a regular person
of strong mental fortitude sees dumb
stuff on the internet they are
discerning and they can reject or say
that i don't you know i don't trust this
or i'll research or i'll look into it
more but when stupid people see it they
just plug right in and say you got it
and they follow along with whatever
nightmarish trend happens and that's the
crazy thing you know i see a lot of
people tweeting like i wonder how it
went how how did people let it get to
that point and you know throughout
history i'm talking i'm not talking
about world war ii because it's over
over um
it's it's cited so often it's you know
godwin's law but you think about any
dictatorial uprising how did people let
it happen we had a guy in here who was
fighting against castro when he was a
young man he was castra took over and it
was like it was a revolution and
everyone was cheering for then slowly
and slowly and slowly castro kept doing
more and more script things until he
controlled everything and it's like how
did people let that happen
because one small thing at a time
i'm not going to stand up and i'm not
going to say anything that might upset
the people around me over this small
issue and then it just piles on and
piles on and piles on and before you
know it it's far too late to do anything
ian people don't have a world convention
and your leaders is so dangerous having
faith in other people blind faith for
sure yeah it's not that obviously i want
to have faith in you you guys like we're
talking i believe in you as a human i
have faith that you're going to do what
you say you're going to do
but
there's like a level up there's like a
a diminishing return to that like you
gotta
believing that they're gonna do what
they tell you whoever they are whether
it's you or you like there's it's
dangerous that's dangerous and if you if
you authorize some sort of massive
political power and you just believe
they're going to do what they say i
don't like it well i don't think it's so
much blind trust in leadership as much
as it is not voicing your opposition
when you clearly don't trust them i
think a lot of people don't trust people
in power and i think that they know that
there are very screwed up things
happening in the world such as the
things we were discussing earlier with
human experiments being done on innocent
faultless children
but they just don't say anything because
it's uncomfortable because it's
unpopular
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you